Valyria was young and as the young do it
sought to spread its seed its first
daughter was volantis an outpost on the
mighty Rhoyne River at the frontier of
the Empire there the Dragonlords raised
the famous black walls seamless fused
dragon stone 200 feet tall and so thick
that six four horse chariots can race
along the battlements side-by-side as
they do each year to celebrate the
founding of the city to this day only
those who can trace their ancestry back
to old Valyria are allowed to dwell
within the black walls
none are even permitted to set foot
inside without an express invitation of
a scion of the old blood meaning of
course the ancient and noble blood of
foot soldiers for the city's first
hundred years its only inhabitants where
it's garrison but where soldiers go vice
follows taverns and brothels began to
sprout up outside the black walls and
merchant ships began to call as well
bearing the favorite trade of the summer
sea slaves the east bank filled with
homes shops and society and so the
taverns and brothels moved to the West
Bank where foreigners sell swords and
pirates erected their own shadow city of
fornication drunkenness and murder in
time the West Bank became such a cesspit
of crime depravity that the volunteers
had no choice but to send their slave
soldiers across the Rhoyne to restore
order and some semblance of decency like
all such missions they succeeded they
left then they failed when the
volunteers grew weary of shipping their
soldiers across the Rhoyne every year
they built the famous long bridge of
volantis strong enough to support the
weight of a thousand elephants and many
more soldiers the long bridge of
volantis stands today as the longest
bridge in all the known world
the Valentin rulers intended the bridge
to spread the civilization of the east
bank to the west instead the depravity
of the West Bank spread east shops 10
taverns inns and brothels line the
bridge most three or four stories tall
with each floor overhanging the one
beneath it one can buy anything on the
long bridge or steal it if one's hands
are quick enough but if they're not
though at least half the deck [ __ ]
committed no greater crime than
displeasing a master for in volantis
there are five slaves for every free man
a proportion matched only by the cities
of slavers Bay the volunteer masters
mock their property with facial tattoos
permanent and scarring which denote the
vacation of the slave slave soldiers
were green tiger stripes upon their
faces slave [ __ ] are marked by Tears
beneath one eye the slaves that collect
the dung of horses and elephants are
marked with flies the drivers of the
half A's the carts pulled by the small
elephants of lanterns are marked with
wheels and so on a master may give his
slave freedom but no man can give a new
face is it any wonder then that the
slaves and freedmen have turned in such
great numbers to the priests who preach
of a cleansing fire the temple of the
Lord of Light in volantis is said to be
the greatest in all the world larger
even than the great Sept of Baelor all
who serve within this mighty temple are
slaves Porter's children and trained to
become priests temple prostitutes or
warriors and one could argue its
adherents outside the temple are slaves
as well in mind if not in body magic
trees nobody except its practitioner to
do what he will with those who can't
just as the black walls free the old
blood to see what they will without
those they don't but one must wonder how
much longer such freedoms will endure
when across a source one hears the sound
of chains breaking of slaves rising of
dragons roaring volantis may call itself
the first daughter of Valyria but it is
not the last
you